For these marchers, Rosa Luxemburg and Karl
Liebknecht are real heroes.
Thousands turned out to mark the 100th anniversary
of the deaths of the communist leaders.
Trudging 15 kilometres in the rain to the
couple's memorial.
Rosa Luxemburg and Karl Liebknecht were murdered
100 years ago.
Their struggle still counts.
We can see that in the rise of militarism.
The problems that we have have with racism
in Germany, the swing to the far right.
Those are all reasons why we're here."
No doubt, Rosa and Karl are their big idols.
These people here believe they must continue
the struggle the socialists and communists
started 100 years ago.
That's when tradition began.
More than 100,000 followers flanked the coffins
of the two revolutionary leaders.
Luxemburg and Liebknecht were captured and
shot by right-wing paramilitaries.
Their deaths are still controversial today.
Australian Tekle Setargew is studying physics
in Berlin.
He's active in leftwing student politics,
and an ardent admirer of Rosa Luxemburg.
Rosa Luxemburg, she was important figure,
she was revolutionary.
She was also a very strong feminist.
She is one of the first women to find her
voice and make a powerful stand in the time
where even revolutionary discussions were
dominated by men.
The marchers make their way to Berlin's Central
Cemetery.
It's a place of pilgrimage for the Left in
what was once communist East Berlin.
Wreaths and carnations are laid.
Tekle finds it encouraging that these historical
figures remain so significant.
For us, they represent our fight to improve
conditions for all workers around the world.
And the society we are living in, we still
face the same conditions: workers, students,
families, they are still exploited the same
way.
We have to worry about our rents, having jobs
and becoming homeless and it has impacts all
over the world.
Across the way stands another memorial, this
one to the victims of communism.
It's often ignored.
But for this visitor it's important to lay
flowers HERE.
I think there's always a risk of the two of
them being romaticised.
It's important to remember the other side
of the story, that's if we want the whole
truth is to be told."
Whether Karl Liebkecht and Rosa Luxemburg
were responsible for crimes committed later
in the name of communism is debatable.
But there's no doubt that the 100th anniversary
of their deaths is being used for political
purposes.